[Music]
okay everybody i am so thrilled today
because i am joined by carrie elways aka
miles aka the duke of dunbar in a castle
for christmas on netflix this friday how
are you doing today carrie i'm doing
great thank you so much thank you for
having me
yeah i love we have a special guest here
too is that what's the dog's name this
is parker
and decided he didn't want to miss out
on this particular interview so it's all
right he's going to join us but if he
gets to be too rambunctious uh i'll send
him on his way
no i love it i love this surprise guest
this is very
going to hang out down here okay
no yeah what i love it um so carrie i
have to ask you about this film how do
you find that sweet spot of this
character you play it so well where
there's a tough show but he's really
likable and charming what's the secret
for you when you play roles like that
well uh
for every role that i play i always find
i work with the director and the writer
very carefully to
to explore what what their uh
what their take on the character is
obviously
and then i try and find
ways to make that character to human as
human as possible i try and find things
that have happened in my life that i can
use that are relatable that might be
helpful
um
i like playing characters that are out
of my comfort zone i like that obviously
i'm drawn to those kind of roles if you
look at my career um
and what what makes them tick what are
their hopes what are their dreams what
are their fears what are their
um you know all of the all of the things
that make us who we are are the things
you want to try and hopefully uh
get across to the audience and this
character was a very interesting guy i
mean it's someone i've never played
before he's an introvert and
kind of a hermit and and grump and a
little bit like scrooge you know from
from a christmas carol sure
and he literally
is not looking for love and he's not
looking for any companionship
but this girl is this american played by
brook shields sophie brown wanders into
his life and he just completely turned
she completely turns his world upside
down and so uh yeah i was really drawn
to the to the character and and and
playing as a scottish person who i've
never played before
and i just jumped in with uh with both
feet
yeah i mean i love the wisdom you're
giving just about this type of part in
particular especially because you have
the books behind you i feel like i'm
just getting this great uh knowledge um
but when you're doing a film like this
you just mentioned brooke shields
what is your approach to
build that chemistry with the other lead
and a rom-com like this well i mean you
always want to get to know the person
you're working with so spend quality
time with them um i
knew a lot about her work obviously
beforehand i'd studied her career and
i'd followed it very closely and i
knew that she had great comedy chops so
i was i had no fears on that front um
and you know you just hope that you
end up working with someone that
that you're compatible with and that you
get along with and and brooke is you
know i mean she's just so easy to get
along with i mean she's hilarious and
funny and a great wreck on turn
and we hit it off right away so i i
always gauge it by that i'm like i hope
and pray i get to work with someone who
who is like me that they don't take
themselves too seriously but but they
take the work seriously and um and she's
very much like that
yeah and
it shows on screen how professional you
guys are and just pros and
having that you've done this for so long
do you feel acting is just easy for you
now or are you still always learning
like is there always more to learn
always a learning curve it's a
never-ending uh education the day i
think i know it all is the day i should
quit
right
i love that um
and you know what too just what i love
about you carrie is that you always
still embrace the princess bride and
share posts from fans about it and do
you think that's important for actors to
even embrace like things that are really
dear to fans i like that you have that
about you i mean you have to it's the
fans that made those films famous so if
you don't
you know uh what would be the point of
my
turning my back on my fans they're the
ones who put food on the table and they
and they thank you chris
and they um they're the ones who've
supported me and support my career and
they're the ones are going to come out
and see this movie so i i i never take
them for granted my fans they're the
ones who've given me the incredible life
and career that i have today so i'm
eternally grateful to them and the
principles of course yeah
love it there you go fans you're hearing
it from the man himself carrie elways
watch him work his christmas magic this
friday in a castle for christmas on
netflix carrie thank you so much for
joining me and i hope to see you in the
future one day thank you i hope so too
thank you